you know I'm going to dip back and forth
between comedy and and horror because I
I love to do that but you've talked a
lot about how the British office was
influential for you when you when you
saw that and particularly Ricky J's
portrayal in that David Brent that was
something that spoke to you yes although
that I that doesn't seem really hip to
talk about right anymore right that must
have been an interview from I know but
I'm saying I'm like I'm trying to go
back I'm trying to go backways but how
when you were getting into comedy was
that something that interested you at
all or no so yeah I mean look that
honestly it's I I I have you know D I'll
be honest D is like a cringe Factor
these days yes and I love him he's my
he's he's um he's a genius and I um
cringe Factor because he's always trying
to step on the line step over the line
well yes yeah something like that but
it's what we it's what we love about I
think it's like figuring out out that he
is more Brent than we
realize which is his genius it's his
genius so he's an absolute genius he
knows this I know him and um you know
what I'd say about the the office when
that thing came out I thought it was the
first thing that um was able to play
uncomfortable and awkward and and play
this entire new side of Comedy right
that I felt like was so cringy MH and
and welcome so I I think it's like you
know to to address his um the the the
master that is uh uh deras and Merchant
it's like cringe Master generals yeah
and so as as a
horror fan um they're kind of they're
they're goated in a certain way right
but I don't think it's like cool to be
like hey let's talk about let me talk
about you how cool cooled your vas is
right
now well that's what first of all we
never this this is not this is not this
is not a cool podcast this well look I
mean this is not so you're free I mean
we're not here to just talk about cool
stuff cuz I'm here well that's the thing
that's the saing tell him how much you
love Kevin spy just tell you okay spy
what Spy did don't I don't want you to
fall for that okay I won't fall for it
what I'm trying to say is and thank you
for stopping me cuz he's always trying
to get me in trouble this is what I have
to say about the whole controversy that
just happened mhm I it does it feels
weird to talk about someone like jaas
when I'm in the presence of you MH and
I'm not joking it feels like what we
what are we even doing here right well
you don't like that you're the I'm
calling you the goat like it's like why
are we T you know don't worry about what
I said in 2009 about deres you're here I
like that but he's very uncomfortable
with compliments well no not not not not
from this man oh okay I'm I'm taking a
day off of being uncomfortable or on
compliments okay cool you're right I am
the goat well everybody I don't
like that best you ever
lived also a great painter and athlete
no I did not mean to break cun and this
is
not look you are I'm an amazing
lover I go all night long well what what
happened to me I blacked out and said
and then I woke up and I just smell
burning rubber and I don't know what
happened I feel bad now we had um I mean
I I I feel like I've produced a film
with you let's talk about that yeah
because uh do you feel that way well we
had you and I had an interesting uh and
I don't know where this is going or what
you're doing with this project uh but
but I'm I'm just going to say that I got
this invitation to uh uh go to your
office and I didn't know anything about
what was going to happen and then um you
had this it was absolutely fascinating I
think it was over two hours you and I
and I think you've done this with a
bunch of other people but you just
presented me with a bunch of decks of
cards and I would select different cards
that would lead us towards the making of
a movie yeah and so I'd pick a you know
you'd start out with genres and I would
just pick three genres and you and I
would talk about them we produced it
together and this is your life your life
is making films that is your life now
and you're making these films and you
think about it and you're clearly
extremely gifted at it and this is what
you've been put here to do and then
there's me and I'm just firing all these
ideas at you about how we could make
this movie it was really fun um so let
me I'll give you a little do you think
we ever do you think we ever got close
to making a movie together that could be
made yes yes our premise was was solid
okay okay and you were a big part of
that now wait can I backtrack for just a
second and and because this is something
that these are these are a bunch of
sessions I've been doing with people who
I whom I admire uh the the Ryan cougers
the Paul Thomas Anderson of the world I
I don't know what what's going to happen
of these but they really are amazing at
sort of like learning about how other
creative people think about the film
making process right the
Daniels um we uh some just incredible
filmmakers and then con
It Well Done um you got to break it up
every now and then you know every now
it's like this is this amazing French
meal VC swas and you know just perfectly
baked you know steaks and everything and
then every now and then you got to just
have New Perspective
yeah loops Froot Loops with a big with a
lot of almond milk and so the whole
thing was we did a we we ended up it's
kind of like DN D and D but making um a
movie and it's a fake movie and we ended
up making a a Christmas movie a
Christmas movie yeah we ended up making
a Christmas movie that I remember
thinking at the time I absolutely think
this could be a Christmas movie yeah
that's the fun I think this could be a
Christmas movie and we're not you I
don't want to get too much into it
because uh we did record it so you never
know this could be something I know what
you're doing with all this uh it could
be a movie I did but spoil away I don't
care okay well
we we had uh it was it was really fun it
was a lot of fun and it was really
fascinating because um my thing is to
just pitch pitch pitch pitch pitch and I
threw so many bad ideas at you and my
favorite part was watching the light go
out of your eyes when I'd be going down
a really bad Road and I'd see you go
okay
uhuh yeah uh Conan uh maybe and we were
really had to act like we're going to
pitch this in a meeting with Executives
so sometimes you'd say just don't do
that whole run in the the meeting with
the executives yeah that's right that
was really fun we had to well yeah and
you had to you had to talk some actors
off of some Ledges and stuff because
that's part of part of the game is every
now and then you say okay now it's time
to pick a disaster like there's a
there's a there's a a Kur fuffle there's
a problem so you'd playay out other
cards cuz there all these different
decks of cards and I'd pick one out and
it would say you know your actor has
lost his mind and runoff set who was the
bad egg woody woody harlson was causing
us some problems problem yeah anyway
it's um which just you know I think the
minute you draw the Woody harelson card
you know he's going to be causing
problems trouble I we were shooting on
location uh and um but I you sent me in
to deal with Woody a bunch of times um a
deal with Woody and his and then uh also
Jen Aniston was part of our because that
was one of the cards we drew right and
um I was not allowed to speak to her
well it's a wi Choice as as as a
producer we made some
early decisions that was really funny
choice I remember it I was just not
allowed to just it's very real you were
so good I could see why you're very good
at what you did cuz you were very gentle
with me but you were like Jordan I was I
was legitimately honored I just knew if
I could um mine you know that gold yeah
yeah you know in this in this way we got
yeah it's like okay and we had I think
also Charlie thin is in there and you
and you were saying like yeah L I'll
talk to them I'll talk now why don't you
go talk to
Woody Woody's in the trailer go hang out
with Woody and I'll I'll deal with the
ladies and I'm like all right okay I
still don't understand why I can't have
dinner with
them but I mean all uh you know just out
from the in the context of the of of all
these sessions I've done it's just I
mean that one is just going to live
forever for me it's like holy I
just got to like movie improv with Conan
basically f it was really fun we had a
very good time um you know I want start
to kill momentum with another compliment
that's okay he always fast forwards them
or takes them out I take them right out
yeah